heute wurde bundestag bei der
generaldebatte heftig diskutiert der
oppositionsführer friedrich merz machte
seinem ärger über das zaudern von olaf
scholz in der ukraine luft der konterte
mit ankündigung weiterer
waffenlieferungen hören wir einmal in
die debatte ein
die kommenden wochen werden wir auch
weitere waffen liefern zum beispiel hat
die bundesregierung aktuell entschieden
dass wir mit den systemen iris t das
modernste flug wer abwehrsystem liefern
über das deutschland verfügt mehr als
einen monat nach dieser gemeinsamen
entschließung im deutschen bundestag
sind der ukraine bis zum heutigen tag
die zugesagten waffen nicht geliefert
worden mehr als einem monat statt dessen
werden von mitgliedern ihrer
bundesregierung der bundeskanzler und
aus ihrer partei heraus ständig
irgendwelche behauptungen aufgestellt
die schlicht und einfach falsch sind sie
telefonieren 80 minuten mit dem markt
mit dem russischen staatspräsidenten
und morgen kommt der
parlamentspräsident der ukraine nach
deutschland nach berlin und sie
verweigern ihnen bis zu dieser minute
einen gesprächstermin alles was sie
sagen ist nicht richtig wir machen das
was möglich ist allen rezession war
herr kubicki sie sind selbst in der
regierung mit der fdp können sie das
ärgernis von herr scholz überschuss von
herr merz verstehen also zumindest kann
ich verstehen dass oppositionsführer die
rechtliche frage stellt warum wir mehr
als einem monat brauchen einen beschluss
des deutschen bundestages der mit großer
mehrheit gefasst worden ist umzusetzen
dafür gibt es bisher auch keine logische
erklärung aber ich bin nicht teil der
regierung ich bin parlaments
vizepräsident teil des gesetzes
aber nach wie vor steht immer im raum
wir liefern wir liefern wir liefern wir
kündigen als andere wahrheit das ist so
gab es bisher keine kein transport von
schweren von schwerem gerät in die
ukraine denn hätte geben müssen früher
ja zunächst einmal ist die sprache jetzt
im frühjahr geben können ich glaube dass
schon weil wir wie gesagt sie haben das
angekündigt bei den tag 98 sind man
hätte bereits ende februar sie mit der
frage beschäftigen müssen
wenn die ukraine dem russischen angriff
stand hält geben wir jetzt rheinmetall
die genehmigungen für ein gefragtes
material instand zu setzen um bis zu
liefern dann wäre es jetzt bereits
geliefert gucken wir bei alldem was die
bundeswehr hat wirklich nach was
brauchen wir unbedingt zur eigenen
verteidigungsfähigkeiten bunten ist und
was ist kurzfristig auch sozusagen
lieferbar und ich glaube schon musste
mich darauf die aussagen meine
verteidigungspolitische sprecherin und
vorsitzender des streits immer man
verlassen die ja anders als ich auch
einblick in geheime unterlagen hat wenn
sie sagt wir hätten mehr tun können dann
bin ich sicher werden wir tun können
freitag den hätten wir mehr tun können
hätten wir mehr tun müssen steilere
waffenlieferungen für die ukraine die
frage ist doch wie helfen wir den
ukrainern am besten und ich glaube dass
mit mehr waffen und immer mehr schweren
waffen wie den ukrainer nicht helfen
weil dir damals mit schweren waffen wird
der krieg verlängert kriege werden
geführt mit waffen kriege werden aber
beendet mit verhandlungen selbst der us
amerikanische außenminister blinken und
der generalsekretär der nato haben heute
nochmal gesagt dass nur mit
verhandlungen dieser krieg beendet wird
und ich sehe nur dass wir seit monaten
ständig tagein tagaus immer nur über
waffen und sanktionen sprechen aber
nicht ansatzweise wird energie darauf
verwendet wie können wir einen
verhandlungsfrieden in der ukraine
schaffen damit das leisten ist untersagt
entschuldigen sie also aber wenn wir
über auf diesem niveau hier diskutieren
wollen darüber könnte ich mich gleich
verabschieden herrnsheim aber nichts ist
zu hören dass sie von den
verlegungen das weiß ich nicht wirklich
entschieden zurück und hören sie auf mit
dieser kriegspropaganda was hat nur weit
über gewalt und jeder der gegen
waffenlieferungen in diesem land ist der
gegen die sanktionen ist wird als putin
troll oder kreml apologet oder sonst was
die verlassen 1 3 der kriegspropaganda
das hat mich doch mal rein und marita
resolut das ist teil des militarismus
der sadist militarismus zu tun
eine solche gegenseitige sondern würde
putin mit seiner armee alle ukraine
töten dass es nämlich sein zu jeder der
nicht bereit ist in den krieg zu ziehen
gegen den äußeren feind wird hier zum
inneren feind erklärt und das weiss ich
zurück das hat mich schon über 100 jahre
den deutschen ländern dürfte jenigen die
gegen den ersten weltkrieg waren als
zaren versteher diffamiert worden sind
wir sollten wirklich damit aufhören es
gibt ein legitimes interesse von 50
prozent der bevölkerung in deutschland
die laut umfragen gegen die lieferung
von schweren waffen sind wollen sie
behaupten dass 50 prozent der
bevölkerung hier irgendwie putin das ist
doch absurd das ist wirklich gelungen
lassen sie uns doch darüber reden ich
sage ich habe meine meinung ist dass ich
das für falsch finde diese politik der
waffenlieferungen und der sanktionen die
eigentlich ein schuss ins eigene knie
sind hier in deutschland wenn man sich
mal die zahlen anschaut beim öl embargo
beim totalen energie embargo und das
über die sanktionen nicht im jahr aber
wenn wir zurückkommen zu den beiden
strategien finde ich falsch
waffenlieferungen und auch die
sanktionen ja einfach sagen so keine
überrollen lassen reisegutschein oder
nur noch mal kriegsverbrechen begehen
das wieder passieren keine waffen die
man sie jetzt hier live show abliefern
die frage müssen sie beantworten hier
musste die truppe aufgehalten werden
soll wie ich sagte wir müssten wirklich
versuchen an den verhandlungstisch zu
kommen es gibt schon die russen hier
einfach lustig wollen was wäre es
erhalte ich das halte ich für ein
gerücht zum beispiel es gab ja es gab ja
tatsächlich versuche von istanbul
angefangen beispielsweise und washington
post guardian new york times und viele
andere haben mir dann gesagt dass
besonders die us administration die aber
sehr widersprüchlich ist also meine
kontakte in washington sagen dass es da
unterschiedliche meinungen gibt die
einen haben die linie chirurg times zum
beispiel die sagen der kriegt muss
beendet werden und man braucht eine
verhandlungsstrategie
und die anderen sagen wir müssen mehr
waffen ifa aber es gab diese versuche
dann muss noch mal zu besuch sind
offiziell erklären putin selbst auch
offiziell erklärt wenn die ukraine
kapituliert dann ist frieden aber das
würde bedeuten sie besetzen die ukraine
mit ihren russischen truppen auch ohne
ideen widerstand
ist auch das
ein bisschen sachlicher zu machen statt
nur so ein austausch von emotionen
ich halte es für keinen zufall dass
deutschland noch keine schweren waffen
geliefert hat ich halte es für absicht
es ist keine unfähigkeit die schweren
waffen die deutschland ja x-mal
angekündigt hat der bundeskanzler muss
man genauer sagen werden nach meiner
auffassung oder sollen nach meiner
auffassung dann geliefert werden wenn es
schon waffenstillstand gibt die sollen
später erst ein treffen und was heute
angekündigt worden ist das
luftabwehrsystem frau bernburg hat
sofort anschließend gesagt wird mehrere
monate dauern bis das geliefert wird
alles dauert mehrere monate auch der
gepa panzer wird erst im juli geliefert
und das war sofort geliefert werden
könnte wird nicht geliefert da sieht man
die absicht an der der schützenpanzer
marder könnte sofort geliefert da gibt
es auch viele von beständen der
bundeswehr
die werden den ringtausch aktionen die
dann wieder ewig wochen dauern an
griechenland geliefert an tschechien
geliefert die sollen dann kaputte
sowjetische panzer an an die ukraine
liefern das ist alles zu auffällig ich
glaube dass die bundesregierung und
vermutlich auch paris eine strategie
verfolgen sie wollen den zeitpunkt
abwarten der ist ja nicht mehr so fern
dass russland die gesamte ost ukraine
den don was erobert hat weil dann
vielleicht die chance auf ein
waffenstillstand besteht weil die russen
das erreicht haben was sie als erfolg
ausgeben können plan a ist verliebt die
ganze ukraine zu besetzen gelingt ihnen
nicht mehr plant das ist plan b also die
krim weiter zu besetzen den landwirten
nach russland und die gesamte ostukraine
und dann zu behaupten dass er das
kriegsziel gewesen und ich glaube er
kann ja er kann ja sozusagen den don was
besetzen und sagen wir machen scheint
verhandlung dann machen wir wie man
weiter niemals wieder nach das kann
schon sein dass man niemanden oder
jemand weiß ich werde auch nicht darüber
was putin bild das weiß ich nicht
wahrscheinlich nicht mal vermutungen an
aber ich glaube dass die in berlin das
kanzleramt und paris auf diesen punkt
hin arbeiten und deshalb
den vormarsch der unbestreitbar ist der
russen im donbass nicht durch neue
schneller waffenlieferungen aufhalten
wollen die vorsitzende des
verteidigungsausschusses frau strack
zimmermann fdp hat ja gefordert sofort
oder möglichst schnell besser gesagt
marder panzer schützenpanzer an die
ukraine zu liefern davon gibt es
ungefähr 380 in beständen der bundeswehr
das wäre nicht schwierig 50
dann werden halt neue produziert und die
füllen die reihen der bundeswehr wieder
auf dann wenn man wollte könnte man man
liefert ja auch funktionsfähigem martha
an griechenland und dann tschechien aber
an deen an die ukraine nicht man will
einfach nicht der kanzler will nicht ich
finde um das mal zu sagen ich bin so
sauer mit dieser für mich erkennbaren
linien der bundesregierung
waffenlieferung und stellt die richtigen
waffenlieferungen wenn man verhindern
will dass die russischen truppen über
die grenzen des donners hinaus wieder in
die ukraine reinkommen muss man sie
jetzt befähigen dem zu widerstehen und
ich würde eigentlich erwarten dass jetzt
mal der zeitpunkt kommt man es sieht ja
dass die grünen ganz anderer auffassung
sind dass die fdp durch frau
strack-zimmermann auch anderer
auffassung ist die sollen doch mal
solche wohl ein wirkungsvolles die
sollen doch mal ein wirkungsvolles
ultimatum erklären anstelle der grünen
würde ich mir hoffnung dass uli moment
dass die sagen in 14 tagen während 50
marder an die ukraine geliefert oder
diese koalition ist zu ende das erwarte
ich mal um druck auf scholz habe ich
hier so ein bisschen der punkt und hier
würde ich gern einen punkt von frau da
gehen gerne aufgreifen der bundestag ist
der meinung und services der meinung von
sammer ist der meinung ich halt mich
jetzt hier mal raus was meine meinung
ist aber da ist natürlich die sache die
umfragen stimmen dass 50 prozent der
bürger nicht der auffassung sind mit den
schweren darüber diese großen stimmen
nicht doch noch 80 nh umfrage ist 50
dagegen empfiehlt sich dafür aber
der punkt ist ja der wie wird man
überhaupt alle bürger abholen können
sowohl als journalist als auch als
punktloser ist ja peinlich könnte denn
auch ein atom krieg ausbrechen also
theoretisch kann natürlich alles
passieren aber ich glaube wenn wir angst
und sorge und angst und bange sind ja
dann sind wir schlecht beraten von da
ist es die falsche strategie ich glaube
wenn wir darüber sprechen was möglich
ist
und olaf scholz im bundestag sagt er tut
alles was möglich ist dann ist das
falsch das muss ja auch mal festhalten
das ist das erste das zweite wenn man
der überzeugung ist dass wir weniger
waffen liefern sollten dann sollte man
das auch erklären aber olaf scholz
erklärt einfach viel zu wenig
kommuniziert zu wenig und nimmt so die
bevölkerung nicht mit und ich glaube
deswegen gibt es eine große
verunsicherung meiner meinung nach gibt
es diese verunsicherung auch weil nicht
genügend erklärt wird warum schwere
waffen notwendig sind weil er zaudert
weil er zögert weil er erst diese sache
ins spiel gebracht hat und gesagt hat
wenn wir schwere waffen nicht von dann
drohe ein atomkrieg das hat er damals im
spiegel interview gesagt sind gemäss um
dann ein paar tage später aber doch ein
bisschen schwerer waffen zu liefern also
ich glaube ist es vor allem momentan was
olaf scholz angeht und die regierung
angeht ein großes kommunikationsproblem
denn man kann sehr leicht erklären warum
es auch aus deutscher strategischer
sicht richtig ist schwere waffen so lief
wird nur das spornt geliefert worden ist
ja noch gar nix an kleidern versprochen
worden aber es ja gut ist wurde
zumindest dann werde man im hansa abwehr
dinge wurden dann geliefert dass es
nicht genug dass stimmen zb wissen wir
gar nicht was alles geliefert wo es
vorhanden neujahr sieht es ja leute und
verteidigungsausschuss die schon
informiert wäre ich will listen wir aber
das wird nur das versprochen was nicht
sofort lieferbar ist das ist der punkt
ich glaube es gibt eine verborgene
agenda des kanzleramts des
bundeskanzlers und vermutlich auch von
herrn mack und dem französischen
präsidenten
die russen nicht daran zu hindern durch
schwere waffen die den donners komplett
zu besetzen um dann zu sagen darauf zu
hoffen auch dass putin sagt jetzt habe
ich ein ergebnis erreicht mit dem ich
mich sehen lassen kann die ganze ukraine
kriege ich nicht und jetzt reden wir
über waffenstillstand und frieden das
ist für mich die verborgene agenda von
kunst ist diese verborgenen
die muss also verborgen sagen weil ich
ich habe sehr sehr viel übrig
spekulationen von journalisten ich kann
nur feststellen es gibt einen beschluss
des deutschen bundestags der auch die
regierung bindet so schnell wie möglich
schweres gerät ukraine zu schaffen
findet nicht statt und das norder wir
haben bereits im märz hatte zugleich
gesagt die haben vier wochen gewartet
wir gucken uns das marie agnes strack
zimmermann gesagt
bis ende juni an dann brauchen wir eine
erklärung warum das was möglich ist
nicht ja das also sie hat das ja als
ultimatum verpackt obwohl ich gegen
wollten baustrahler ist immer man habe
herzlich panzer firmen herr jörges ich
halte ich halte jetzt auch ich halte es
auch für für nahezu fahrlässig zu
erklären es gibt eine heimliche agenda
von westlichen staaten doch ein
wesentlicher teil der ukraine durch
russland erobern zu lassen ohne was
dagegen zu tun einen der hoffnung in der
hoffnung dass man dann einen längeren
frieden sichern kann diese hoffnung auf
zuverlässigkeit der russin hat sich mit
dem einmarsch der russen ukraine
komplett erledigt nun früher mit sofern
eigentlich sagen ich sage spät also
spätestens mit dem einmarsch bei mir mit
dem einmarsch in die ukraine hat sich
das erledigt und deshalb ist ein
vertrauen darauf dass wir einen
waffenschein hingekommen der längere
zeit andauert naiv das würde dazu führen
dass wir unsere kräfte wieder
mobilisieren sammeln und dann aber es
auch im zweifel nicht nützen würde die
ukraine mit waffen auszustatten denn die
russen haben aus dem erstmaligen
angriff auf massiv gelernt dass sie mit
anderen taktischen vorgehen würden und
was folgt daraus nicht leben wollte ich
aufhören daraus dass man darauf hoffen
dass die ukraine das oder rausschmeißt
das ist eine illusion das sieht dass
irgendwelche was befähigt werden die
russen einen verhandlungstisch zu
zwingen weil die russen mit ihren
möglichkeiten auch nicht weiterkommen
momentan ist es so alles was wir wo sie
angeboten haben war kapitulation der
ukraine dann ist es dann gibt es keinen
krieg mehr ist ja logischerweise van
essen dann ist vorbei dann würden sie
aber trotzdem ihre einflusszonen in der
ukraine gewinnen dann haben wir
insgesamt nichts gewonnen die bremische
und gar nichts und ich glaube wir
sollten davon abstand nehmen der ukraine
zu erklären was wir glauben dass sie tun
oder lassen sollten wenn die ukraine
sagt wir brauchen jetzt
verteidigungsfähigkeit und wir sagen wir
wollen ihnen helfen ihre souveränität zu
bewahren dann müssen wir dazu beitragen
dass ihre verteidigungsfähigkeit
herstellt